Hello everyone, this is Dr. Conner's again and welcome to module six of this stop,
Fighting Cancer Course. So this one is about,
Cleat up the environment. Oh, you would just think of environment like
our yard or the environment in our neighborhood. We're really talking about the environment
of your body. Of course, clean up the environment of your house, we could have an entire module
on that. Maybe we'll have to have that a some notch all about making sure that you're not using
chemicals and things in your cleaners. That's not what we're going to really talk about here.
We're talking about your body here. So really, when we're understanding a clean environment,
we're talking about terrain theory. That's one word for it. We used to call it your balloon. Your
balloon is how your cells are functioning or dysfunctioning is in part to their environment. The
balloon, the terrain of the cell. What is your body bathing in from internal perspective? Well,
years ago, this germ theory, when that came out, was going against the older theory of terrain
which was cleaning up the environment versus well, every disease is caused from a germ. Well,
you know what the what science is like when something new is discovered? Well, that's it. And all
and be all for everything. That's what it was when when the finally the genome was mapped out.
That oh my gosh, we're going to find that human genome is so advanced that that's what controls
everything is our genes. Well, we found out that's not true, right? So it was the same thing back
of the day when germs were discovered. When my crop microscopy, the degree of ability to
magnify something was developed to the point where they could actually see bacteria and different
microbes that could cause disease. Well, when that was discovered, then it was thought that microbes
cause everything and all diseases caused by microbes. Well, I am not against germ theory
understand. And I don't think it's germ theory versus terrain theory like many that your
opathy clinics might be pushing. But we have grown the medical system is completely out of balance
in that everything is germ theory meaning that it is the microbes that are causing everything.
And if we just killed the microbes, then we would solve our problem and not realizing we need to
clean up the environment. So there's going to be a balance. Louis Pasteur was the person who really
pushed germ theory, but interesting on his deathbed, his last words were that germ theory is not
correct. It's all about the terrain. And Antoine Michel is the one who was really pushing the terrain
to clean up the environment. So it's easy to understand and we have little graphics like this
that the terrain is very important. But let's not forget, we do still need to deal with the
microbes. If you have an over abundance of microbes, no matter how healthy your terrain is, you could
get sick. So we don't want to be too dogmatic there. It's really this soil versus the seed,
you know, what causes a, I'm a gardener. I love to garden and I love to grow things. And I have a
huge vegetable garden while my wife has this huge flower garden. And we are very understanding the
fact that our soil is everything. So we're constantly adding compost and doing things to the soil
naturally. We don't use chemical fertilizers. And certainly we don't use pesticides and herbicides
and all that garbage. But working the soil to keep it as pure and clean as possible, healthy with
good microbes and having a healthy microbiota of the soil is going to produce the best plants.
Ill soil, sick soil is going to produce a sick plant because the root is really where it gains its
nutrients and where it feeds the rest of the tree or the plant. So that healthy plant is coming from
healthy roots. Well, so it is with our body. Our health, our overall health is going to come from
healthy cells that are feeding off of good nutrients in a healthy environment. It just makes sense.
If you're listening to this, this is nothing new. You guys already understand this. But what we want
to dig into here is understanding how we get rid of poisons that we're exposed to,
regardless of how clean we eat and how clean we've made our environment where we're not
exposing ourselves to poisons and toxins and everything. You are still being exposed to, you know,
maybe a hundred times more toxins that our ancestors were. So that is the key. No matter how
well you do at, you know, organic living in one sense, you're still exposed to way more toxins
than your ancestors. So you have to be detoxing. So the truth is, is your body is always detoxing.
And if you're not detoxing, it will be a very short time before you're dead. So your body has
different organs of detoxification. Your major organs are your liver, your kidneys, your colon,
your skin, your lungs, how you get rid of poisons that you're exposed to on a moment to moment
basis. But let's talk about these phases of detoxification because I think this is really important.
So important that I wrote a book about it. And normally when you hear about one of the phases of
detoxification, those are phases of detoxification that are listed in physiology books about the liver.
So you have phase one, liver detoxification pathways that are controlled by certain genes,
phase two that are controlled by other genes. Those are your congregate conjugation pathways.
And then phase three, your pathways where you are creating bile and and bonding the conjugated
end products to bile to get rid of them out of the body. That's usually where it ends.
Well, as I was doing a talk one day, this was several years ago, I would say that's really not
where detoxification ends in order to where it starts. So you once you put the end points of phase two
into bile, that's phase three. We'll talk about it in a second. It has to then go through the
colon bile duct to the gall bladder and then be excreted into the first part of the swollen test.
And then it has to travel through 25 feet of the small intestine and 10 feet of large intestine
to finally be deposited into the toilet. Well, all sorts of bad things can happen between the liver
excreting the bile through the colon bile duct and it emptying into the toilet. And that's where we
can have major problems. So let's go through some of these quickly. And I'll share on this
stop fighting cancer series more videos about the book that I made and also a free download of
that book that you could have as well. So the truth is we're all poisoned no matter how well you
take care of yourself, no matter how well you eat even if you're eating all organic, you're still
exposed to glyphosate, other pesticides, other herbicides, that no matter what there's cross
contamination, it's everywhere. So just get over thinking that you are living such a clean life that
you're protected yourself. So phase six, so when I said there's phase one, two, three that are going
out of the liver, let's go down to the end point first. Phase six is a limitation. This is a picture
of an aloe plant because Cape aloe is a wonderful aid to elimination, meaning if you have some
constipation problems, using a little bit of Cape aloe can really solve that problem. It can stimulate
peristalsis, that's the contraction of the muscles that surround the intestinal wall and it can help
draw water into the to the colon similar to magnesium and it can help eliminate it. I'll share a video
in my book in the seven phases of detoxification book. It has a bunch of different products that you
could use with this. I don't want to bog down this module with that because I have that in another
place. But proper elimination, if you're not having at least one model one a day, you're not
properly eliminating. So even or not, I've had people say, oh yeah, I have good model movements, normal,
I have them every three days, just like clockwork. Well, you are severely constipated and you are
severely poisoned in yourself because if you're not getting out, what's on the inside, you're
absorbing that and you are making your body extremely toxic and you want to get cancer, then be constipated.
So that is the key. If you are not eliminated at least once a day and a good elimination where you're
getting everything, oh, just felt like you ate the day before, then you're absorbing all those
poisons and you are making yourself very toxic and very sick. Phase five is binding toxins in the
gut, binding toxins in the gut. So even if you're having a daily bowel movement, did you feel like
you're emptying everything out in the gut? All the poisons that your liver has gotten rid of
or hopefully the poisons that you did absorb that you were exposed to through your diet are in
the lumen of the intestine. So technically they're not inside your body if they're in the lumen of
the intestine. So they're in a tube within a tube of your body and you want them to stay in that tube
to end up in the toilet. So in order to do that, using certain binders can be very beneficial. Here's
a benefit of fiber. There's all sorts of different binders that are on the market, charcoal, and
sodium alginate, and we can have a list of a lot of them. But using binders can grab onto stuff
in the gut and hold it in the gut so you don't reabsorb it. This is a very important phase, especially if
you have a cancer that is hormonal driven. Beaded if you have ERPR or HER2 positive cancer,
you definitely want to be using binded agents so that you're grabbing onto hormones because
the number one thing that will be reabsorbed in the larger intestine will be bad astrogens. So
this is a key component for everybody but it's certainly a key component for people with
hormone positive cancers. Now understand a lot of the foods you eat have binders and are
bite-dead agents. So a lot of the fibers that you eat fiber acts as a binder. It can help
you from reabsorbing toxins. But especially if you're dealing with cancer or serious disease, you
want to add some binders to your diet as well. Phase four is moving bile. So remember I said in
phase three, bile is created in the liver and bile is a fat-soluble substance created in the liver.
That's where your liver that's what your liver uses to deposit all of the poisons that it filtered
out of your blood. It deposits it in the bile. So from phase two liver detoxification pathways,
it deposits these toxins into the bile. The bile flows down your bile duct and into your
common bile duct that part of it came from your pancreas. So now it's the common bile duct and it
goes into your gallbladder. If you've had surgery and you've had your gallbladder removed,
well still, bile is flowing down your bile duct, common bile duct, and now directly into your
duodenum, the first part of your small intestine. But if you still have your gallbladder, it's flowing
then into your gallbladder. Well, bile can become quite viscous. Meaning it becomes thick and it can
become bulky, especially if it's full of a lot of toxins. And even more so, if you have other issues
like fatty liver disease, which is very, very common, or you're exposed to a lot of poisons that
heavy metals that your body's dealing with, toxins all the time. The common bile duct can become
more rigid, less flexible, and bile can become very viscous and can flow slowly. That can be a
blockage. Think of your gutters of your house if you had a bunch of leaves in it and it's not going to
allow the water to go out. Well, the gutters are going to overflow, right? Well, your liver doesn't
overflow. It just backs up. And then you can't filter things through the blood, through the liver,
because the liver is stuffed. So, helping to move the bile physically can be beneficial. You can take
things like things that help produce bile. This would be help for phase three. Also, low bar to
choke can be beneficial. Phosphatinal coldine can be very beneficial. But one great thing to help
with phase four is just putting a hot pack over the liver. Also, what really helps with this too
helps with phase one, phase two, phase three, and phase six is doing coffee edibus. So this is one
of the main reasons why you would do coffee edibus. You could help move bile. There are logically
speaking, remember, all your cells are controlled by neurons from an electrical standpoint.
Neurologically speaking, this is controlled by your parasympathetic nervous system. So,
your parasympathetic nervous system has to do with a made cranial nerve, called cranial nerve 10.
It's also called your vagus nerve or your vagal nerve. Your vagal nerve also goes down to your rectum.
And that's what stimulated when you do coffee edibus. So really the primary purpose of doing coffee
edibus is to stimulate the vagus nerve. By stimulating the vagus nerve, you're stimulating the
parasympathetic nervous system. By stimulating the parasympathetic nervous system, you're stimulating
detoxification, you're helping with phase one and phase two from a neurological perspective,
and you're helping with phase three and four by getting that bile moving. Also, your
gallbladder is controlled by your parasympathetic nervous system. So anything you can do to stimulate
your parasympathetics the better. Side point, your parasympathetic nervous system also controls your
immune system. What do you need to fight cancer? You need an immune system. So the reason why you do
coffee edibus is not because you're constipated, you do coffee edibus to stimulate
crediola, tend to stimulate your parasympathetics to stimulate your immune system to stimulate your
detoxification process. So that's what you need to stimulate healing cancer. So you have to move bile.
So doing coffee edibus can help here. Doing a hot pack over the liver can help here. Doing
castorial packs over the liver can help you. And I give some other ideas in the book as well.
So very important point. Then I clump these together. Phase three, creating and binding to bile,
leading you're taking the phase two conjugated in products of phase one and you're getting it into
the bile. Phase two is a process called conjugation. That's where the phase one in products from the
P450 pathways then are changed into a less toxic substance, fat soluble substance or water soluble
substances that are put into the bile so that you can excrete them ultimately in the toilet.
So phase one and phase two are controlled by your parasympathetics and then genetically
by your P450s and your P1 pathways and your multiple other genetic pathways. That's why we do
genetic testing honestly because we really want to see the health of these detoxification pathways
so that we can support them because there are some nutritional pieces that you could use to support
them if you have let's say a lot of defects on your P450s or your P1 pathways. How can we support
those if I have a lot of defects so I tend to have sluggish phase two pathways. So think of it this
way. Let's say two people are twin brothers and they are grew up in the exact same household but
it's because your twins doesn't mean your genes are the same. Let's say one of the twins has a lot
of defects other phase one and phase two pathways and the other one has less defects other phase one
and phase two pathways. The one that has more defects is going to detoxify things more slowly.
So let's say they're both exposed to the same amount of glyphosate from eating corn and the
cob from their farm that they sprayed with road up. So the one who has less defects will be able to
get rid of it much better than the one who has more defects. So the one who has more defects that
glyphosate is going to stay in their system be deposited in the cells could end up causing cancer
months, years, decades down the road and they can't figure out why they have cancer.
Well one of the reasons can be because of the defects other phase one or phase two pathways. That's
what we want to look at it because if you know prior to getting a serious disease you can actually
support those pathways and if you know when you have a serious disease supporting those pathways
can be really important. I know I'm talking really fast and I apologize that you might have to listen
to this twice but you guys are smart and you can fly through this stuff so this isn't anything new.
And then phase zero is detoxifying the tissues. Now the way the reason why I listed this way this is
where everybody wants to start. So they want to start like oh my gosh I'm really toxic and I did this
heavy metal test. So I want to go and buy these key laders that are going to pull the toxins out of
my body. Well if you don't deal with all these things first and you are constipated and you're
not binding toxins in the gut and you are moving bio very well and you have sluggish phase one phase
two phase three pathways and you're going to pull stuff out of your tissue. It's got no place to go.
And it's just going to circulate and either make you very sick or could even kill you in a more
serious way or it most the time it's going to just circulate somewhere else and deposit somewhere else
that a healthy thing to do. That's why some people will detox and they'll get sick. It's because
their phase six five four three two one are not functioning very well and they're trying to pull
stuff out of the tissue. Not a good idea. Don't do that. So you could do all of this concurrently
but make sure you're doing all of that. You have no business doing the chelation
somebody that is constipated. If you're a practitioner listen to this. Make sure you understand that.
You have no business trying to key lay toxins out of somebody who isn't moving their bowel and
you're not addressing by deed. You're not addressing some other issues. You're going to you can make
the person sicker. So make sure you're aware of that. So the other thing to think of is to slow
the toxification. We talked about this at the beginning of this module but starting to learn to make
some better decisions. We have all our patients do this. Now most people are much more educated than
10 years ago. 20 years ago when I used to teach us stuff 30 years ago. I remember 35 years ago having
seminars in my office trying to explain calcium and vitamin C. Well you know now with the internet
people are much more educated. There's a lot more information and I don't have to talk so much about
the rudimentary things of health. But making better choices just about things that you could be
exposed to could be some of the simplest things that you could do that really could improve your life.
You know I can't buy all organic. It's too expensive or I can't buy all organic. I can't even find it.
Just download the clean 15 dirty dozen list. I just got this off the web and this is from clean food
crush. They put this together a wonderful little info graphic. These are your dirty dozen are the
most sprayed chemically induced products on the market that you can buy. We're all talking about
fresh foods and vegetables here. So that's what you should be trying to stay. That's your first
choice is trying to buy fresh foods and vegetables in the outside of the grocery store instead of on
the inside of the grocery store. Stay away from that as much as possible. But and then look at the
things that are more clean that you could probably eat with with less chance of of issues. I don't think
I recommend that this list is cord is almost all genetically modified so you want to make sure that
that's organic. But you don't need to be so specific on avocado speed organic because they're just
not very sprayed nor are most melons very sprayed. But tomatoes are sprayed pairs and apples are
sprayed heavily strawberries are probably one of the most toxic things out there that are so heavily
sprayed. So you want to buy those things organic. So there's just some simple things to dig into.
If you want to really go deep then start watching some of the videos for my cancer genes series. It's a
free video series on different genes that we look for when a person has cancer. It's not a book.
It's actually a video series that you can get on our website. It's free. Understand all our
information is free. I feel like this is a ministry. We're just trying to help people learn and
take better care of themselves. But this is what you look at different genetics that we talked about with
phase one phase two pathways. There's a whole bunch of other metabolic pathways that you look at.
When you're trying to help with detoxification pathways oxalates and histobines and all sorts
of different stuff. So we can get really deep on that. But simple Simon try to look at your clean
15 dirty dozen things and understand the detoxification pathways as best as possible. That's going to be your
best life saver when you're dealing with a sick diagnosis, the cancer diagnosis. So
download my book. That will be a best thing for you.